I tweeted this out this morning if you
take the Chicago election results map
and place it over a racial demographics
map what you get is probably
unsurprising black neighborhoods voted
for Lightfoot a black woman Hispanic
neighborhoods voted for Garcia Hispanic
and white neighborhoods voted for uh
Valas and some Johnson Valles is a white
guy now it's not absolute Johnson is a
black man as well but this is a
fascinating thing here's the map you can
see and uh the maroon is vallus a white
man the uh burnt orangish is Johnson who
is a black man the purple is Lightfoot
you know Lori Lightfoot they call her
Beetlejuice and the green is Garcia now
you may notice that there's a big chunk
of green here and green here well let's
uh let's start with this here is the
here's a map of you know it's really
annoying that the wait wait let me see
if I can uh
shrink this down somehow no actually I
can't oh a little bit maybe it can't
scroll won't let me scroll so uh oh well
it is what it is actually maybe I can do
this
there we go and now I can shrink it yeah
all right nope still didn't work all
right never mind so you take a look at
this you know what we'll just we'll just
go right for the map here you go here's
here's here's the race and ethnicity in
Chicago map
and uh here's White
you can see up here on the top left
narrow hair it's all white you can see
here it's it's moderately what you can
see right here it's all white you can
see down here there's some white you can
see here and here and uh and then let's
take a look at the Electoral election
results map hey look at that the white
area the white area the white area they
all voted for a White Guy take a look at
this let's go back and check out
Hispanic here you got a big chunk right
here in the middle right here and down
here and what do you see go back to the
electoral map hey look at that right in
the same place they voted for the
hispanic guy now hold on Ward 10 you
might say voted for the white guy ah yes
but 36 percent for valus the white guy
in 35 for Jesus G Garcia the hispanic
guy in a neighborhood that is mixed
between white and Hispanic they voted
mix and then of course if you go back to
the racial demographic Maps Maps and
look at black you'll see this whole area
is black community and right here as
well and then you look at the electoral
map and sure enough
the only thing that apparently mattered
to people in Chicago was the race of the
candidate how about that I'm sure a lot
of people were concerned about policy
I'm sure a lot of people if you take a
look at this area Logan Square up to
Rogers Park this is the Hipster portion
that's wokeness these are the woke left
people and they voted for Johnson and
he's to the left of Lightfoot there you
go he's the last one yeah so for them
it's policy but they're also racist so
I'm unsurprised so there you go right
yeah I I was looking at the map and the
breakdown and I was wondering like why
did Lori Lightfoot lose she's an awful
mayor and here's the thing everybody's
talking about like oh wow she came in
third place she got defeated in a
landslide no she didn't she got the same
amount of votes she got last time
the only difference this time white
people voted wow they're locked out
they're shut down so I'll call them
crime and there were eight crime as a
result of the shows vallis ran almost
exclusively on crime crime as a result
of a cabin well I mean a lot of things
but you look at his website and he's got
a tab on the menu bar for issues and
then right next to it is crime and then
he's got a report crime so his campaign
website was encouraging voters to report
crimes to him that's how much crime
motivated white people to vote well and
what you're talking about you know this
because you're from Chicago and I I can
say I'm from Chicago or I cannot say it
now that I'm outside okay suburban
Chicago I spent enough time there
um but that pink area to the right
um is I mean that's a lot of lib white
woke women in that area so which one so
Linkin Park so the low up north oh yeah
through Gold Coast Gold Coast Linkin
Park you know Wrigleyville that and then
you start to get into the uh Johnson's
area there there
um you know that that's the wealthiest
part of the city yep so
but even here in the southwest but
that's also an area that has always
really been immune to Crime the Gold
Coast Lincoln Park I mean and that just
has not been the case so people who've
lived there safely thought they could
walk to the restaurants you know that's
you know I looked up the Gold Coast I
mean it's like it's it's locked down
yeah I looked up Lori lightfoot's
election results and she got like 88 000
votes in the last election which one or
which one the first one the previous
election and then this time around she
got uh I think what did she get uh no no
she got like 92. she got 87 000 votes
this time around putting her in third
place if she got only a few thousand
more she would have beat Brandon Johnson
and then if she she needed what nine
thousand no not even seven thousand more
not even seven thousand I'm sorry
seventeen thousand my bad about 17 000
more votes and she would be in the
runoff with Paul vallis and that's what
happened last time she got around 90 000
votes went into a runoff and then she
won my prediction Brandon Johnson wins
okay based on this map showing you that
the black neighborhoods voted for the
for for uh if you look at the the black
neighborhoods the top candidates votes
Lori Lightfoot Willie Wilson and Brandon
Johnson the top three they're all black
if you look at the white areas it's Paul
vallas Brandon Johnson Jesus Garcia it's
mixed my prediction is the black
neighborhoods will likely vote for the
black candidate in the runoff not the
white guy giving Brandon Johnson the the
tremendous Advantage just uh to win so
it's kind of disheartening to be
completely honest that you look at like
the Hispanic neighborhoods and they just
vote for the hispanic guy and the white
neighbors voted for the white guy and
the black neighbors voted for the black
lady so what do you think is going to
happen then you're gonna get here's my
prediction in the future I think we're
going to start seeing a tremendous
amount of black politicians and to a
lesser degree Hispanic and Asian but a
tremendous amount the reason is
conservatives don't care about race if
you have a Larry Elder or Thomas Sowell
conservatives are gonna be clapping and
cheering for him they don't care what
his race is they care about the policies
and the ideas the Liberals and the left
are extremely racist they won't vote for
a White Guy which writes real problems
for the Democratic party that's why they
you know want a Kamala hair or something
like that so what will end up happening
is you're going to have in this scenario
it's a perfect example Brandon Johnson
don't know his policies don't anything
about him but if we're seeing
by neighborhood people vote
predominantly based on a race
what's going to happen
white people will be split between
vallison and Johnson because you're
going to get a mix of the college
liberal types in Logan Square Rogers
Park who are racist who won't vote for a
white guy then you'll get the more urban
conservative types who will vote for the
tough on crime guy then you'll get the
black neighbors voting for the black
candidate and you will ultimately end up
with more black candidates winning in
the long run also when a white person a
black person have a baby they have a
black baby they call it mixed but like
Barack Obama you call him a black guy
this is a white mother and this is
something that I was told since I was a
little kid being mixed race I was told
that on the on the census I am not a
white person that the the even though
I'm 75 white according to the US
government I am not white that's how it
works so I'm like I I don't I don't know
but my point ultimately is this if
conservatives are not racist and they're
willing to vote for anybody
and the left is only willing to vote for
minorities that's going to create a
tremendous pressure in One Direction
away from White candidates well I think
in Chicago and Johnson is far more
Progressive even more so than she is I
think he wants a city income tax I think
he's defund the police guy uh he's was
bolstered by the Chicago Teachers Union
the most powerful political interest
group in the City by far and I think
after crime education is a huge one you
have hugely dropping
attendance and
participation rates in Chicago Public
Schools especially after lockdowns and
of course Chicago public schools had one
of the longest lockdowns and Paul of
Alice so education is a big issue
Paul vallis is the former education
secretary in the city he worked for Rich
Daly I believe he was his education you
wouldn't call it secretary head of
education so he's got a very strong
background I think he also was in
filling in a few other cities
so I think that that is sort of his
Advantage but I think you know it wasn't
that long ago Chicago you know they
voted for Rahm Emanuel obviously Rich
Haley won I don't know how many terms
four so you have Valas who is a Daily
Democrat which a lot of people nowadays
call Republicans
um versus a very far left
um uh candidate and Johnson so it's a
it's going to be a big you take a look
at these uh the black neighborhoods and
you can see that Lori Lightfoot Willie
Wilson and Brandon Johnson are all the
top in Ward six Lori Lightfoot has 38
Willie Wilson has 22 and Brandon Johnson
has 18. that means when it goes to the
runoff why would they vote for vallis
they're going to vote for Johnson he's
their third pick not vallis he gets
their vote and so then you look at Ward
11 vallis and Johnson are Valles is 58
to Johnson's 14 to Garcia's 13 but I
think Johnson still gets an advantage
there you take a look at the woke areas
I I trust me guys if you don't know
Logan Square is I used to live there
that's right me too young Northwestern
is up north of here that's right and you
got like Loyola up here as well and so
Brandon Johnson's already winning in
these places so then you look at this
over here Brandon Johnson's got 19 Val
has 50 I think you give all of the all
of these areas already leaning slightly
towards him plus just take a look at the
vote Lori Lightfoot and Willie Wilson's
votes if you take 87 let's just call it
90 plus 45 so you're taking uh an extra
100 and you know 40 000 votes on top of
Brandon Johnson he crushes Valles I
don't see Val is picking up the rest of
the votes and I'm gonna say it I don't
care what what the left says you can
clearly look at these maps and see that
people were just voting for the race of
the individual that's it it makes but
you know what it could be it could be
simply put if you're a guy if you're if
you're from Little Village if you're
from Ward 12 and you're Hispanic you
know that Community better so it makes
sense when you're campaigning and saying
stuff like hey I'm gonna help with these
issues the people who live there are
like hey those are issues I know and so
Lori Lightfoot knows these areas but as
much as I think it's fair to say there's
a component there I really do think for
the most part the people in Chicago have
proven they're simply voting based on
race now for the people who are voting
for Paul vallis this is what I was
saying I think conservatives for the
most part don't care they're just like
if you're tough on crime I'll vote for
you Lori Lightfoot is not that fun crime
that's why you can see up in these areas
Johnson gets a portion of the vote and
valus gets a portion of the vote he gets
the most of the vote but I think what I
just think it's clear as they right
there that people just care about race
well it's it's definitely really you're
right your observation is correct that
it is based you know racially how it's
segregated is how it was voted but
correlation is not a proof of causation
so it's you know keep that in mind when
making claims about why people voted
sure and that's why I said there's a
possibility that you know Garcia
gives a campaign speech
and because his experience comes from
the same neighborhood it resonates with
people in that neighborhood does he
speak Spanish
that's a big who yeah
his real name is Chewie uh I think it's
something else but that's what they call
him so if people if you speak Spanish or
your parents are like you're from Mexico
or something like that that I could see
why you would vote for someone that also
spokes oh for sure I mean he's been
around I mean look man there's a reason
why everybody lives next to the people
of the same room there's a reason why
the neighborhoods are all segregated
people choose to do that the government
like redlining and blockbusting ended
blockbusting into the 80s red lightning
ended a long time ago people now just
choose to live next to people who they
look like and look like them
so this this like
I think that the Democrat critical race
Theory leftist stuff makes this worse
and is exacerbating it absolutely
absolutely I believe that the whole like
let's let's get a woman of color as our
vice president like that obsession with
race and gender or I guess sex and race
you're going to see it all over the
place I mean Chicago's always but it's
been a city whose politics has been run
by race for a long time I mean you go
back to the days of Harold Washington
and you know that whole Wars of the
early 1980s
um that was uh you know when he was the
first black elected mayor I think in the
country maybe he was the second
um so it's not necessarily new but I I
don't know I'm going to disagree a
little bit I think I think there's
different Dynamics you think for the
runoff than just race
I think there's I just think it's a far
more
um complicated complex
based maybe I'm being naive what do you
think what else do you think I I I think
it is education Paul of Alice his roots
to the city you know he's not like the
old business guy or say a Rahm Emanuel
or somewhere he's got he's got good
credibility and a good background in
what he's done for the city and I do
think his background in education
um you know crime being the major issue
there I think uh what's happening in the
schools is a major issue to to a lot of
these parents now I I mean I don't think
I'd be naive enough to think that you
know a lot of those neighborhoods a lot
of those Wards regardless of what
situation they're in would consider
voting for valus
um but I do think it's a little bit more
nuanced I think than race
I think that obviously there's a lot of
things that play a role when you look at
the Rogers Park stuff these are clearly
you know more white areas that are
voting for a black man obviously for but
that that falls in line with that um
there was a study done that shows the
different racial breakdowns in their
in-group out group preference and white
liberal is the only group with an out
group preference makes perfect sense
when you look at this that's right so
these neighborhoods they probably care
to a certain degree about policy but I
mean you look at some of these places
and it's like you know in Ward 18 which
is I believe Ford's it's probably Ford
City area okay you've got actually let's
just do this
it's uh uh so here we go it's Ford City
you've got 15 or so uh uh white
population and I'm sorry that's a black
population it's uh 27 22 you know
percent white it really does correlate
like this area is split between white
legs mixed so you get Lori Lightfoot
then Paul vallas but then you go into
the areas that are more heavily black
and it's Lori Lightfoot Willie Wilson
and Brandon Johnson like even Johnson
who's far left it seems like race played
a bigger role than anything else so I'm
sure you could probably say 40 of the
vote is is due to good policy but
because of race being a predominant
issue for most people I guess the way
they see the world that ended up being
the dominant Factor because that's what
manifested in the map you can come out
and be like no no everyone voted on
policy and I'm like yeah but if you look
at the map it's near one for one with
the racial breakdowns of the city and
who they voted for
that's kind of disheartening isn't it
yes maybe that's just reality you know
you can't feel one way or the other
about it I was thinking the other
yesterday or today or something like
when we talk about race like you got did
people say white and black is a race but
it's the only ones that aren't like uh a
country I think I mean there's Latino
but is that a race Asians are continent
like so there's there's a Russian
they're they're they're from Russia or
like Caucasian the Caucasus then all of
a sudden you have black and white which
are like what how's that there's black
people all over the world from Haiti and
from Africa and from you know East East
Asia and things like that so like what I
don't know the I don't understand race
the whole concept of race is very weird
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time